Donald Trump taking on liberal America
the latest examples the president who
made his name in New York now escaping
the high tax state for Florida of course
leftist lawmakers are ripping Trump for
changing his residency I don't believe
he was ever in New Yorker anyway because
living in New York does not make you a
New Yorker to be a New Yorker is a state
of mind it's a set of beliefs so I say
so I say so I say good riddance good
riddance mr. Trump and disastrous New
York City Mayor Bill DeBlasio telling
Trump don't let the door hit you on the
way out so much for being inclusive
Trump also continuing to call out
California for its out-of-control
homeless crisis the president hitting
Democrats like Nancy Pelosi for not
fixing the problem it comes as a new
report shows homeless death rate in LA
County has jumped by more than one-third
meanwhile in Chicago the president
slamming the city shooting epidemic
Trump continuing his feud with Chicago's
police superintendent that going down
while we got this very sad news a
seven-year-old shot in that city last
night while she was trick-or-treating
Greg yes a lot to choose from here yeah
story the segment began is something
really really fun and then somebody got
a hold of the beginning in turned it
into something tragic I don't know look
I would move from New York in a second
because of many reasons two reasons why
can't Fox is here and my wife okay so
here's my analogy about New York's New
York City in California have you ever
been around a supermodel or a
professional athlete they're amazing to
look at but they have no personality why
is that because they never had to work
on that facet right they didn't have to
try hard they just look beautiful or
incredibly athletic that was all the
attractiveness that they required that
is New York City in that is California
you have high taxes you have bizarre
crazy crime you've got homelessness
people leave but people still come so
what happens is because it's such an
attraction traction to people young
people primarily to move to New York
city or to move to California the
government can be as inept as possible
they don't have to do anything because
they know the tax base is going to take
care of it so you can have these
wildfires and and you know that people
aren't going to leave insurance is going
to take care of it people are going to
move in you can have tragic homelessness
in LA
tragic homeless in New York City drug
addiction high taxes but you know what
for the 50,000 people that run away
fifty thousand people are going to come
in because New York City and in LA and
San Francisco there's super models well
and yes and the show we'd like to
apologize to supermodels and athletes do
you have personality I didn't say all of
them I said some and that's the
supermodel I can say this right what do
you think it was nice for de Blasio and
Cuomo to just say you know don't let the
door hit you on the way out you're not
even in New York or to begin why the
president built New York to get out of
here okay he built more buildings in de
Blasio in Cuomo is that right yeah well
you know what normally I get into it
with you but now the rest of the crew is
laughing okay but let me just say this
to me is all about president front
trying to save money on his taxes so
it's all about like Americans we would
like to know more about his taxes but
the fact is Florida has no estate tax no
sales tax right no state tax right so
that's what he's doing so this is not
about oh these people have been mean to
me this is about greed this is about him
simply saying this is it's a selfish
move so and it has not I would say I
will say that he has gone after big
cities in the most direct way you know
these what when he passed that tax bill
what he'd say state and local taxes now
no longer covered why because that means
that if you live in a big city that
you're going to pay higher taxes that
was a direct strike from President Trump
and his administration against people
who live in big cities and to Greg's
point hello so let me get this straight
its life is so wonderful in the rest of
America but some reason we're so dumb we
don't move to Arizona
Arkansas Arkansas Mississippi not like
they were again New York I like you're
an American you're moving to the big
city yeah but you you you you mutated
what I said I said people are leaving
but more people are coming in and
they're generally younger people yeah
and you talk about greed don't I love
when liberals talk about greed like this
somehow wanting to keep more of your
hard-earned money when you go to work
and you get a paycheck and you want to
take that money and give it to your
family you don't want to hand it over to
the government which often times uses it
completely inefficiently somehow that is
not now equated with greed that's that's
those people's money to spend so
everybody around the country if he is
making that decision because he's
looking at the taxes like so many
Americans that are taking not only
themselves in their families but they're
taking their businesses to the likes of
Florida to lie sub Texas the same way
Amazon came here and they were rejected
and then they went in they said all
right we're gonna go to a business
friendly environment what is wrong with
that the bottom line is that every one
of these liberal cities you look at San
Francisco you look at Los Angeles you
look at the leadership in those places
they are part of the reason that those
cities are in the position that they are
in and they keep doing those things over
and over again they refuse to
acknowledge that what they're doing in
those places isn't working Nancy likes
of Nancy Pelosi busy talking about
impeachment out there and all that she's
not addressing what's going on in these
districts you cannot shame people for
looking at the environment in a place
and saying this environment is not
friendly to diversity of thought this
environment is not friendly to low taxes
or making me keeping more of my money so
I'm getting out of here he should be
commended for that I know what Juan's
point too about greed Donald Trump
doesn't take a salary as President
Barack Obama he did anyway Dana what do
you think about this president he's
first Republican president a long time
to you know go after Chicago go after
homelessness in LA this really has the
Democrats on their heels they don't like
any criticism so and the problems have
gotten worse in the last decade so the
the issue of governance is the one it
really matters right so people aren't
just leaving
because of the taxes they are leaving
for these other problems the the in how
long will I lived here in nine years so
the ink the decrease in quality of life
in the city I mean from this area
through the park I think it's visible I
see it every day it gets worse every
year and so when you start talking about
more trash that doesn't get picked up
the traffic is horrendous the the some
of the decisions about traffic flow and
things like when everyday life gets a
little bit harder and you have an option
to leave you think wait why am I here
again and you have an option to be able
to leave like people are exercising just
tweeted something she says I Love New
York but New York can never be great
again under the current leadership of
Governor Andrew Cuomo the brother Fredo
or Mayor Bill DeBlasio Cuomo has
weaponized the prosecutors to do his
dirty work and to keep him out of jams a
reason some don't want to be in New York
and another reason they're leaving taxes
and energy costs are way too high
upstate is being allowed to die as other
nearby states frack and drill for gold
oil while reducing taxes and creating
jobs by the thousands and YC is getting
dirty and unsafe again as our great
police are being disrespected even with
water dumped on them because a mayor and
governor just don't have their backs New
York's finest must be cherished
respected and loved too many people are
leaving our special New York great
leaders would work a president and a
federal government that wants our
wonderful city and state to flourish and
thrive I Love New York
you know what he's taking lessons from
Jesse this won't stop he said he loves
New York just shows how much the
president loves us he knows that they
needed a very special episode of the
Trump show and it's like when you when
the Bradys went to Hawaii
that's the Florida we have a whole new
story arc for the next week you know
what he did say something in that sweet
Greg which is interesting that maybe
some of these New York prosecutors that
are moving your home base to Florida
does that protect you in any way I know
I don't know but I think that he they
also recognize that if they were to come
back to New York and have this as their
residence like it would it would never
ever end
yeah next next move the Nassau to escape
Greenland one green way he's saying he
loves me you can love this city and yeah
get big okay what's happening to it and
say this is what makes you and breath
anymore that's gonna be here that's what
gets you mad and and I think that like
when you when I grew up in California
and I've lived here and when you and I
used to go to San Francisco every
weekend I lived in LA and you see and
it's it actually is sorrow sorrowful
when you see it and also he mentioned in
the tweet energy costs that's true
energy there's the energy cost and also
there's the long-term consequences of
energy and environmental decisions
because they're closing the what's it
called up there the nuclear power
station that's up there in the important
well there in the Indian point the
long-term consequences of not having
enough power to fuel this city to keep
it growing is that's why Wall Street
Madison Avenue media all leaving all I
have you bet your front